you are
so good at business and i want to get
into all of it i want to get into the
producing
the book everything that you've built
where you came from
and i thought if you want could we do
things in reverse and kick it off with a
game yeah why not okay all right well we
want to put your skills to the test to
find out is 50 thrifty
um
[Applause]
you may have an economical um name but
let's be honest you're a baller that's
been a little money
yeah what are we supposed to that's how
we can make up for you know the work if
we're not going to enjoy ourselves at
some point right you got to be some type
of benefits we reap yes but we don't
have to just spend it ridiculously so
now let's get through
well
you um we pulled similar items one's
expensive and one's cheap the economical
version and i was wondering if you could
spot the difference
i think i can okay first station we have
two gold necklaces one is expensive and
one is not
50. which one is thrifty
i think the first one is he correct yes
[Applause]
i'm like you know because whenever they
give you a chain and there's like extra
links in the back
that might be the cheaper one
that's so funny because i would look at
that as like the extra step i'm like you
don't know if i'm long or
or short i just know that they ain't no
extra
expensive stuff to give away you just
like now you just
skip what you pay for you don't get no
extra links
okay i am having an aha moment i've
never looked at it that way and now that
i'm looking at the back you're right
this one's a lot more confident yeah
this one had two two it looked like it's
more but no i got to beat you well
you're right this one is like a choose
your own adventure and this one feels
very accustomed whenever you see that is
g
okay i am loving this because i am
learning all right
the next step we have two brands of
champagne um i was wondering if you uh
could taste the difference are you a
champagne drinker a little bit you know
i had my fish here
um well which glass holds the thriftier
champagne
and this is
the fact that you're sticking your nose
in it makes me feel like you're very
confident
[Music]
this is the thrifty one right here
[Music]
number two
see the color of this champagne it looks
like water
there's got to be a sparkling wine or
something like that that looks like they
look like champagne yeah you're right
okay the next station we have two lit
candles um take your time to breathe in
the essence
of each and possibly
focus yourself and waft it up
are you a candle person no but i'm
trying to be on the show
i love your commitment i love you so
much i really do
oh this is this is hard
[Music]
can i look to the studio audience for
some help please
do you guys know
could you just it's only one or two you
could just do put up a number
you could help me just be lucky you
whatever one you oh she said to us two
two's two three one i know cause look at
her that she's right
can't win them all you can't win them
all yeah
so number one is the thriftier option
okay we have one last one there is a bed
here and one of the pillowcases
is very expensive and the other one is
cheap and cheerful
but
we're going to have to touch
and hand feel
in order to know which one is which
can you tell by a hand feel which pillow
is cheaper and cheerful and which one's
more expensive and lux
[Music]
yes yes
[Applause]
[Music]
this one felt like this is like
you get this in the wrist caught
yeah yeah yeah uh-huh so are you picking
that one
yeah that one's got to be the cheaper
one
number two is the cheaper one yeah all
right
and
i can really feel the difference no i
could look this hotel lifestyle
expensive hotel you go get this it's
right here it's caught in here i love it
i got to be in bed with 50 cents
guess what 50 is thrifty yeah
[Applause]
um well the pillowcase one and the rest
of the bedding that you see here is
actually from pact that's the one that
you said feels like red's car l10
it feels expensive it's good it does
feel expensive by the way there was no
comparison on the hand feel
um it's all organic and it's really
comfortable and everyone in the audience
is actually going to go home with a 300
gift card
[Applause]
from enjoy that
what's so wonderful is before 50 even
knew he was talking about how top of the
line and luxurious and hotel like
the interaction was with this bedding
and you all deserve that get up in your
cozy
[Music]